on this episode we talk a little
education we call Denmark would be good
[Music]
[Music]
this is
dare you be
[Music]
everybody carries a workshop and this is
a 240 on the ask guarantee show like
it's good focused in a very very
interesting kind of weekend a lot going
on in the American political system
you know team human is Heloise being so
I'll dress it right away
who's this Azim is Jerry diem you're on
the askgaryvee show
[ __ ] so Gary what's up man where you
from uh so I'm from New York family from
back then but uh very night yeah so you
got a question start off honestly man I
was just going to use this time to say
I'd love to have coffee with you I just
wanted to do my husband as you would
thought this would be the best way to do
it I think it's a really good hustle I'm
not going to be able to deliver on that
because I'm still 700 internal meetings
behind but I appreciate the hustle my
big thing in this for everybody I
appreciate you asking this question
and by the way much love and thanks for
watching the show keep doing your thing
the you know that's devastating like
every vertical will just wet which it
happened I still have 500 internal
meetings but I'm supposed to have in
this company let alone the outside stuff
so when I say I can't and I'm not doing
these copies trust me I'm devastated
that I can't my bigger issue is the only
have so many hours in day between family
one of the big things that translates
ugly 17 is to do more internal and less
external on time to both laugh like a
Michael this is Gary Vee and you're on
the askgaryvee show
yeah Gary Vee a pleasure to speak with
you sir Thank You Man
you're a very busy man we actually got
to meet on my 30th birthday in Austin
Texas we were walking out of your hotel
and I was with my wife and my daughter
oh man I remember that that made daily
be that was on dailyvee did you see that
you know I never thought I thought I
should check but I guess not to go look
at that that's cool voila you run into
me in the street you see me rock is
filming it's your 30th birthday we have
this wonderful moment and you decide not
to even just glance to see if you made
this may be episode I'll have to look at
it I think I've been keeping pretty
pretty busy I was actually giving you a
compliment much respect keep doing your
thing what's your question brother my
question is had the questions ready yeah
I'd like to know a little bit about your
your document don't create details it's
something we've been doing a lot more
and I enjoy hearing your general
perspective on no problem and I'm glad
you're asking thank you so much and and
hope everything's wrong is really nice
to run into you well appreciate the no
worries me I'm going to hang up and get
the next one but I love you and stay
well so Duncan is DHing versus creating
don't dial yet this has been a big break
from so much so as you guys all know
because you've been watching daily be
some of you I really am writing a new
book called crushed it and it's
profiling the people that read crusher
and crushed it and giving you the
updated on what I would do if I was a
personal brand on Instagram or Twitter
or snapchat or having build your
personal brand and endured the business
around your favorite passion be the
queen of strawberries or vegan food or
tailgating or making candles that ethos
that has played out even to a greater
scale that most people believed one that
I believed so much when I did the first
book this document and instead of
creating thing is so big that there's
been nights and showers and just like
jam sessions in my online over the last
month where I'm like should I make that
book should I quickly sneak in documents
and don't create doing it out of big
ethos of crushed it here here's the
punchline what I'm seeing and so many of
you are answering on this is people are
crippled when they have to create
original content but when you actually
understand that you and your life are
the unique piece of creative it changes
everything is everybody interesting no I
mean the answer is no not to the macro
meaning not everybody is destined to
become a social media reality star but
so many people are destined that will
never start so many people like look you
don't have to be the Kardashians right
you can be some version of it here's
what I do know there are a thousand
people watching this right now that if
they started making snapchat stories
Instagram stories YouTube videos
Facebook videos and post three or four
times a day documenting what they're
doing eating
lunch taking my kid to school this is
who my uncle is this is my sister this
is what I'm into this is soccer practice
if they sort of document it instead of
like well let me make a video about like
how the Sun comes up or like instead of
creating something you just document
your actual life
my biggest belief is so many of you
should be documenting your journey of
becoming an intern of becoming moving
from college to the real life going
through your divorce starting your new
business if you document your truth my
belief is that there is a stunning
amount 1000 of you watching right now
who could make as much money and that
might be 80,000 and there might be
380,000 you can make as much money
documenting your life through all these
channels and making monetization through
ads affiliates sponsorship deals
speaking engagements books and all the
other ancillary things that happen you
can make as much money being you as much
money being Tyler babban as getting paid
at vaynermedia being Tyler Babb and in
the production team like I just believe
that truth now that might not be for
everybody but it is for a lot of you and
unlike Tyler Bevins thank God most of
you don't like your job he likes it so
that's what would prevent him and you
may love your job and that will prevent
you but if you were sitting here today
in 2017 and you are watching this piece
of content which means you listen to my
themes and care about my stuff and
you're in this ethos you start dialing
well then you to understand what
documenting versus creating is not
everybody's going to create that show
you know it's a lot easier to make a
documentary than Cheers
if you understand the power of the
current platforms of things that nature
it's not documenting so easy either but
just telling your real life on a daily
basis super interesting to me and
something all of you should at least try
what's the cost a couple leisure hours
on [ __ ] brogurt Derek or what tarik
Turk it's Gary being you're on the show
rock your word yes bro are you kidding
me I'm not kidding I'm [ __ ] really
[ __ ] on this you're on the show I'm
dying right now
where I look where you from my heart is
my heart is pounding I love it oh I love
you Gary I love you so much you have no
idea I love you back for all right where
you from I'm from Denmark
believe you call all the way to good
luck yeah we're going International on
the show we finally figured out how to
lose this thing and call International
so we're going to go International heavy
for a little while now catch up so
what's your question
amazing thank you so much for the love
man you're shining out an Instagram not
so long ago yep amazing sorry I'm going
to the question please
so oh so nervous right now
whatever okay because of you I decided
to go all-in on an idea hat and go to LA
a startup with my friend
and ever since just give me a sec no way
I'm so nervous right no I think you're
seeing you I [ __ ] your Rosie I love you
back brother let's do this alright when
you go to LA with your friends have you
gone there yet or not yet not yet
obviously we just called on one I was
actually in LA I tried to meet you I was
I went to your office because I wanted
to meet you so bad you weren't there you
were in LA I was like trying to stalking
you Obama trying to figure out where you
were what you were there I'm positive
you gotta be some Bay I'm sure anyways
let's get to this question because if
you don't ask this question next five
seconds between the office show and I
will never meet you oh my god
alright so awesome there Mike I'm not an
American citizen yeah I want to go and
start up this company in the US yes um
it's difficult made my partner is from
the US yes what we're trying to do is a
new social media platform within fitness
and health and one of the most important
things for a survivors trying to make a
Minimum Viable Product but I think like
I feel like we're stuck what is what can
I do to make like this happen we have
the strategy in place we have like the
business plan what's the strategist need
[ __ ] business plan your strategy is
to make a fitness social network right
yeah media social media platform Frank
within Fitness okay that's not a for me
that's our thesis it music you have a
strategy you'd be executing against it
you wouldn't be asking me this question
so that you absorb damage or recharge so
we're trying to speak with influencers
everyone everybody everyone everybody
trying to
exactly you want to have the report just
some leverage what are you offering
where we go and we need to go on and
winning vistas right what are you
offering what we're trying to do is like
this platform we can no no what are you
offering influencers that you're trying
to siphon attention out of their world
and want to feel their attention and
take it for yourself selfishly what are
you offering them to be a part of this
we're trying to offering them like like
that this is so difficult to explain in
such a short time we're trying to offer
them to have total new platform take
advantage of their brand and and then
what they're going to monetize off your
platform better than they're monetizing
off into the brand exactly they're ill
be able to market a whole new home
target group in in terms of a lot of
them on Instagram today why what you
have no users Instagram has hundreds of
millions of people on it yeah exactly
we're not trying to take anything away
from Instagram richer time to offer them
the opportunity to monetize their
personal brand character every possible
person is trying to build a platform for
influencers to monetize our brands in
other places and so what clap what
you're trying to do is build a platform
that shares the economics with
influencers who actually have users and
you just want to do that by painting a
picture that they'll make more than they
will on Instagram when Instagram
actually gives them the attention the
eyeballs that they're actually
monetizing awesome oh well this is this
is hard for me to explain Gary I'm sorry
that I don't have a more flowing from
this like this is a group regarding part
no no listen feel free to send me an
e-mail I'll try to read it if I get a
chance but here's what I promise you
everybody is trying to take from
influencers instead of give them and yet
and when you say well we'll give them
better monetization opportunities it's
just not true if you have no audience
not you know that right
if you have not honor we were trying to
reach our to give them a way better
opportunity to talk with their audience
as well and they make sure that the
content that they're creating is not it
will be much more detail
much more cute I can't explain it but I
can tell you that your program no matter
no you're doing everything fine let me
just tell you one thing that everybody
gets wrong if you don't have people if
you want people to give me influencers
and you want them to come on so they
bring their audience you've lost
we will you've lost how much you're
getting the nuchal equity in your
company
you've lost everybody it's a chicken
renegade direct you know like everybody
wants you want influencers because you
want them to bring the million people
that pay attention to them over and sign
up for your world no matter how much
economics you give them your you're
getting more than you're giving them in
that first move which means you'll never
have started you have to solve for that
that's a strategy how do you bring them
more value this is about the actual use
itself but we try to get inferences on
board to have leverage when you want to
talk to some people some investors like
yourself Gary so that maybe the question
is like what do you think is the best
strategy I think the best strategy is
not for universally likely to build
something without being at the mercy of
raising money everybody wants to raise
money by the way if you walked in here
with 15 Fitness supermodels that made my
tongue hit the ground and they had 40
million [ __ ] followers I still have
no interest in investing in your [ __ ]
company don't think that the influencers
on board are going to give you money the
markets very very very tight right now
there's a lot of uncertainty in the US
market these these are not the wrong
around money because you got a couple of
two chicks and guys with six packs and a
couple million followers okay okay I got
you good all right I'll talk to you too
the bank alone I would need to actually
execute on something that shows me
traction not Theory your in theory mode
you have to do it on the best companies
did and then raise money now in the
generation where everybody wants money
first make something make an MVP that
actually works how do you do that work a
[ __ ] side job and use the money for
that to do it like everybody thinks that
money is an entitlement upfront anymore
nobody's giving you [ __ ] money got you
good thank you so much and this is it
like go ahead
and this is this is it guys like and
girls like like we're in this modern era
right now where everybody thinks like
like all this whole strategy with my pic
influencers who have big audiences I'm
going to slap them like they're part of
our thing and that's going to get me
seems to be excited about it's not
really seems to be excite about personal
there's a million influencers there
unlimited or commoditized second of all
you can't explain their product where
you going and everybody's trying to
steal from these employed remember
except the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
strategy I get hit up a million friends
a day I'm gonna help you monetize more
monetize my [ __ ] so don't figure out
of monetize himself it helped me know
you want my dick and then you can
monetize together
[ __ ] you give me half your house and
then we can sell it and make money I got
the [ __ ] house [ __ ] you know I sent
me like through the reason so many of
you are losing is because your model is
predicate on somebody giving you more
value upon your not offering anything if
he answered me precisely and said well
I'm giving five percent of my company to
five different people now you have a
conversation you DM at dunk and say I'm
going to you 11 percent of this sneaker
business now some people look at it not
food give me a soda from a sneaker
business because on my platform more
people will pay attention a cooling fans
on his platform
you got you much [ __ ] dick you got
nothing you wound me first you've got an
empty Club you need to bring the [ __ ]
got it what hello who's this DJ shoes is
Gary geniu on the askgaryvee show
okay this is Gary Vaynerchuk did you put
your number on Twitter to be on my
call-in show yeah great well you're on
it oh whoa the publishers know what yes
man this way my name is Gary Vaynerchuk
gary vee on twitter you put your phone
number i you a show this episode to 40
you're on it what up oh my god i didn't
eat your gear you've got a big heart my
my my my life cooking you can't knock
you I appreciate a man what's your
question
Oh
oh well answer my question purpose okay
the Roman people not some backups for
judge I don't suppose you make some
sense alternative backups or the fear a
browser I'm sorry I couldn't couldn't
learn it so I couldn't hear that very
clearly oh I'm sorry I said uh I'm gonna
ask you a question
well did you come up back up to the
question as well okay because it won't
look that go ahead fire lane help great
so the question is the question itself
is ours your clients at Dan your talents
role with your next move from maybe
meaning if you were to that if you live
up yep I can hear you clearly so if
you're paying me thirty thousand dollars
and you now work advance now you're a
client of Bainer talent you pay me
$30,000 a month we sit the first thing
that would happen is we would sit down
with you and ask you what the hell do
you want to accomplish right if you want
to get a lot more notoriety so you can
write an album do you want to have a
book deal do you want to create your own
social media agency do you want to sell
sneakers do you want to get paid fifteen
thousand dollars a night to spin like we
always go backwards from the North Star
I want to buy the New York Jets so
everything I do ladders up to that got
it fun so that's exactly the things I
hope that's what I want what do you want
those your time on that is oh I want to
tour I want to have our local Sanders
about a moral family that just before my
wedding see what I love to do I love it
it's produced me if you can eat you love
it arm and so here it's kind of like
your registration is a vocational
training and I'm currently stationed
over employee but my thing is is like
how to twelve years ago I'll try to go
all-in with it now but this is what I
thought I want to do I get it I quickly
I was there's nothing to make me happier
so that's what I went all-in on
promising you sir listening no just
hungry I started getting very diverse
people get into grandes you know my
merch healthcare are influencers people
all around terms get that name out there
yes keep going every time not there's
I'm not working I'm in the studio I'm
making the music so my big plan is if
one right now I'm kind of kind of build
brand awareness yeah what matters are
elders not losing
right so keep going however tell however
about nine months I'm going back to the
states and my client then is to go get
my trust to all the big major drug guys
follow out there offering services for
six months to a year for stream call DJ
there's em for free get them values on
that Club then after that Hospital hard
wonderful time I love it Gary are you
gonna be able to find within that right
it's great so that's exactly I love your
strategy are you are you able to afford
to work for free for six or nine months
when you come back to the states from
Italy yeah absolutely sell out really
good for the concept result and that's
not my plan it's time to conquer the
doubt I heard something sounded so much
much much and after that what was my
movie or do I hope you see how was it
discussed touring how do I get okay
well one look one kinky I didn't send a
very basic question once you can get
enough people to give a [ __ ] about you
venues will book you left and right you
can tour forever
and he's not complicated you look at
rough to rapper in Atlanta puts on a
song every week does it for four years
whatever eventually a couple songs pop
it gets a little bit of thing then he
has one song go completely pop crazy and
now he's touring every day who's selling
out shows left to right I mean this is
this is different models you don't need
the Gary Vee show to understand this you
need to put out music every day we're as
close as you can
here's the model you start at the moon
and you go backwards you should put out
music every single day now you're going
to say we'll listen I'm stationed here I
can't do that I can't be that's great is
it 364 days then you can put on music's
great you can it is 360 days music oh
you can't
okay the two hundred ninety days of
music you need to put on music every day
on soundcloud and spotify and then you
need to make as much content on social
media networks to bring awareness you
need to follow hashtag you need to DM
keep on Instagram all the moves that
I've been talking about the real answers
your question is it actually has to work
meaning like you have to have the talent
like like there's no there's no model
like there's no way to become you know
prettier except for plastic surgery and
so then you're dealing with what you're
dealing with like you might not be good
enough to tour at the level that you
aspire to be I don't know but I can tell
you the best way to find
well is to put out music every day yeah
absolutely
okay like there's no secret sauce here
it's putting out content but where
people actually are as often as you
humanly can the end that is the strategy
for all all right first I'm an benefit
like it's like like I've been looking
for some sort of like hack here's a hack
it's in whatever you're producing put
out that product to where it is you're
selling something put on the Amazon
Marketplace eBay store your own store
Shopify like put it out put out creative
marketing videos pictures on all the
platforms we all spend our time on
Instagram snapchat Twitter Facebook
YouTube and just do it as often as you
possibly can and then you'll find out
whether the world likes it or not it's
literally that [ __ ] basic here's the
problem you guys don't want to do that
you know why he's still you know a
hundred percent what's going on here
this town like you know like like a lot
of practice from you know so I you know
I don't I don't I don't a bit of
plaintiff especially more because like
it's really held one more time when we
want for me
there's no cheat code there's no up up
down down left right left right B a B a
select start not in this game you have
to put out the content you got to put
out as often as you can
you got to let the market decide but you
have to be smart about where and how
don't make a speedy and Shop it to A&R
people put the [ __ ] music on Spotify
and sell fast
that's how you get to scuttle off when
you make stuff hello it's Gary here on
the ask Gary Vee show Gary my favorite
corporate job motivator
Julie how you doing I'm good how are you
I'm super well can I answer for you Gary
I just want to say thank you thank you
thank you for everything first of all
Thank You Julie you are the best
what's your good answer for me is let's
talk about high school education okay
what are the top two things that you
think could change your public education
right now for students that are bored to
death at school so help me from you I
want to you know I can talk about things
in general terms all the time having a
Q&A show allows me to be a little more
specific to the person
ah and I want to really deliver for you
so help me understand this you're asking
from what perspective I'm asking from
from an educational from a federal
educational perspective versus what is
have really cashing in high school how
far behind we are wondering where are
you in this are you talking about a
child are you an educator who are you
why do you care about this and what you
do that ties into identity I actually
work in public education love it as a I
work in a high school I'm with 1,700
students a day that are basically not
allowed to either cellphone right and
and you play what role in that world I'm
actually a teacher and a department
chair love it okay so here's what I
think and I think it's amazing to have
you on the call here and we can go back
and forth I think if you're if you're
calling me and you've heard so much feel
then you are an amazing teacher to these
kids because you are not blindly
following the PlayBook that has been
pushed down our throats
on this issue which is you know as well
as I do when you really look at the
curriculum of the average public high
school in America today it's not going
to look terrible but I mean just not
practical so here's what I would say the
number one thing that I think you can do
and I'm not kidding is the following one
by one one by one in the same way that I
do it on social and in life one by one
when you see these kids whether you
whether it's their parents when they're
picking them up or at a sporting event
or when you have a scheduled meeting or
when you see them you have to break the
ethos and have that one-on-one
conversation you need to grab Gary
Vaynerchuk in your class who's a
sophomore right I need to pull them
aside I mean I got several little Gary's
not gonna need your head I've got I've
got hip-hop music kids looks like a
crazy doesn't it maybe a minigame a sign
so listen you need to grab them aside
and you need to give them the wink your
wink may change their life forever you
encouraging these kids what saying I see
you I understand now I can't tell you
what to appease your parents with maybe
they want you to get this diploma maybe
dadadada but I'm telling you my friend
more than anything in the world
mrs. Kennedy Senora Kennedy is the only
teacher I had in high school that gave
me the wink her wing ping by her calling
my mother and saying mrs. Vaynerchuk
Gary's going to get us be in Spanish
this year I don't think he knows how to
say hola but I know that your son is
going to win in life and I know that he
needs to pass Spanish to graduate high
school she gave me the ring I'm telling
you right now 41 years old this link
happened when I was 17 right please
right you're not going to change the
macro thing you know what's going on
this is not something that's going on
it's not very correct so what I want you
to do is be practical you're not going
to change the whole system I'm not going
to make a video that goes viral and
changes the whole system the head of
education now in this country has her
objectives it's going to be very
different than what we've seen I have no
idea where it goes I'm not the kind of
person that thinks all politics are left
or right or all bad or all good I have
no idea I do it one by one but here's
what I can tell you you darling for
calling me and asking me this question
you need to go overboard with those
little Gary's in your class and you need
to give them the wink which is listen to
me Charles listen to me Susan I see you
I see what you're passionate about and
selling [ __ ] is always going to allow
you to be successful in life
so keep trickling down don't you know
don't get me in trouble with your
parents like I'm not telling you to drop
out of high school but somebody giving
them a wink and saying I see you believe
it or not you doing that and don't force
it don't [ __ ] it don't just do it
cuz they barely know like wow the kids
does the [ __ ] they see right so I'm
telling you in reverse they see right
through it the other way you go grab
Ricky out of class and bring him into
your office especially if you make an
impact like that he didn't science class
but somehow you pull them out for impact
and you sit them down and say Ricky you
listen to me you're going to [ __ ] win
I see it i watch your hustle I see your
charisma I see your Drive and I know
it's not to do well on a scantron test
tonight I see what you're doing
want you to know that I I see it and if
I can ever be a help to you I got you
and remember that I fit in a world where
a lot of other people are just going to
go by the book
I see what you got and I'm here for you
and I'm proud of you we need way more
encouragement we need way more
encouragement they're playing in an
ecosystem that isn't practical and then
most of the teachers are just playing by
the book and they're discouraging so
real-life encouragement of our real
truths is the number one thing you can
do
it's the cliche shift you'll help four
kids and you're helping as much as you
can actually do you understand
understand Gary do it a graduate Jake
you man I appreciate you I love you back
thank you all right I love this man
perfectly parent it's coming I know I
got to go nope that's it question of the
day who's the last person that you
positively impacted you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]